what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest
on the channel my little sister amelia
she's super she's super excited to be
here she is 14 years
old has never heard of kevin samuels or
the man of sphere so today
i'm going to be showing her some of
kevin samuel's savage moments
because she would not be she was not
willing to sit down for a full clip so
70 years old as long as i'm not shooting
blanks i can make babies
you can't the reason why
um i became a bottoming technician is
because
there's something called the paramedical
insurance examiner let's get the [ __ ]
out of my phone [ __ ]
i don't get the phone go take blood boy
came and you ain't woke a job where
people quiet in the background
[Music]
have you watched one of my videos
a three-hour video from front to back
background situation when he was ranking
that girl you're not paying attention
when he was what talk to him
i'm just watching one of my videos have
you watched a full video of mine from
front to back
one one of my live streams i just
thought i just saw one video
um was it the whole i think it was a
whole video of some girl we used
when you were he was ranking her he
asked her what her what
what her asked her what she ranked
herself
i have a full three-hour show that i do
and you watched a seven-minute clip
i challenge you and your friend to go
back to my channel and watch the full
30 minute ah now sing i'm not going to
do this
see here's and this is the problem
but you haven't even you haven't even
responded to what i said
you haven't even watched the full video
of where the excerpt was coming from and
then but your friend has the nerve to
make
a judgment that women have no problem
judging me
on partial information please
and you and you women are acting just
like so many women who get upset you
have little
to no information you're not willing to
do the work do you think women get upset
at men a lot
depends do you think they say things
like mine are trash a lot
yeah do you think that's okay sometimes
really depends on the guy you're talking
about do you think but in general do you
think that's okay
like men are trash men are trashed like
just in general
i don't know i don't really have an
opinion on that kind of stuff because
i'm on the opposite side of that stuff
you think women are trash everyone's
trash
let's just settle it like that to ask
you certain questions and what you're
responding to i'm responding back to it
so you're referring to past videos by
referring to
things that you're telling me now but
you don't even let me you don't even let
other people talk
you're asking me how old i am you're
generalizing women
you're not yeah no we haven't had sex
okay
why why because i don't
i'm stingy i'm stingy with excuse me
i'm stingy with it i do not give it up
easily were you married to your were you
married to your daughters
your baby mama right baby i've never
been married no but i just okay
hold on let me let's talk about this
though see
um i find it funny that
women like yourself baby mamas all of a
sudden want to get stingy with the puss
after you gave your womb up before a
ring
but then you want the high-value man to
put a ring on it before he gets it
what am i supposed to give it away you
got damn right you already did
because here's the thing see that's what
i mean
man you're a used vehicle wanting brand
new 2021 prices
you can laugh all you want to man but
you just said six months
you're not even exclusive you talk about
he's marriage minded what do you think
he's inserting his penis in his hand
no that's the thing he could be in
certain somewhere else exactly because
here's the thing men with options don't
play these games
okay hello what'd you think
why all right you were saying
do i want to hear about your original
plan
okay no and i will tell you why
you're not doing it you're doing what
you have to do to survive
and live okay okay
so your original plan it doesn't matter
it it does if it can change my situation
i mean i don't i mean go ahead dude
the reason why um i became a provider
technician is because
there's something called the paramedical
insurance examiner
i'm not sure if you heard about about
that doesn't matter go ahead
i don't i don't have to know what you're
going to do all right all right look at
it man don't be a [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] off my phone [ __ ] i don't
get the phone go take blood boy
came you ain't broke a job where people
quiet in the background
[Music]
well kevin uh mr samuel it seems i'm
just i have a question did you date 30
year old women
because you mentioned on the last show
and that is a question why yeah i mean
if you're doing it why would you say
you're
cause okay first up let's how about okay
you want to answer that question
it's a double standard just like
you can stay at home well i got to go
work if
i was at home and you worked people
would look at me a certain way this is a
double standard that's been with us
since
time immemorial do you think that's true
there's double standards
there's going to be a double standard
for literally everything
does that make you mad or do you not
care i don't care it's not fair
children can come out of whatever i do
would you be cool staying at home while
your husband worked someday
i mean probably because i wouldn't have
to do anything
like you want to work for me okay go
ahead
would you be okay working while he
stayed at home i wouldn't care
money do you know how to cook and clean
i know how to cook but i don't like
cleaning
i can be 70 years old and as long as i'm
not shooting blanks i can make babies
you can't hey i don't care what you look
like
so i don't know i said no no i don't
care what you look like
before a woman's gonna sign off and
become your missus they're gonna check
their pockets
so don't so so if you ask do you think
women date for money
a lot of women do would you
i don't really care you did it again
it's broke
not my problem you'd be living together
and having kids
you want kids you said date okay sorry
would you marry a guy that's broke
i don't know have you thought about
getting married
no do you want to get married i could be
single and alone for the rest of my life
and i would be happy
you sure about that okay
see think okay here's the thing and i
don't know your first name
so what is it walter walter if you would
if you were to wake up tomorrow be broke
how long do you think your wife would
stay
until i die okay hope hope that never
happens to you hope you never
but that would be the first woman in
here but i went to the first woman
do you think if dad lost all his money
mom would say
i feel like they wouldn't get divorced
but mom would leave
wait really i don't think she would
um not like by doing something
irresponsible just like
i don't know the economy crashed or
something i don't know if he was doing
something dumb then yeah she'd probably
leave for a bit
yeah she come back i don't know not my
problem i feel like yeah if she did
something dumb she'd probably leave for
a second
she'd probably come back where's your
wife sleep was she talking to him
no she just walked up to i woke up i'm
not going i'm not going to inject any
difficulty into your marriage
i got gray in my beard and gray on my
head and uh what you saying just knock
the point anything i've ever experienced
in my living life
you're a very good communicator i know
thank you very much
and that's why i said money is more than
nice it is required
if you expect to have a woman especially
a woman of quality
thanks definitely you still haven't
defined quality everyone's
all right see i'm not gonna go back and
forth with this
again see this is part of the problem
young man this is a man who's sitting up
in the house
with a wife and gonna sit there and tell
you money's nice but
you know his dude is honestly trying to
say
miss walter your husband just said if he
lost all his money
you'd be living right on the corner with
yes ma'am you and your older age because
i'm assuming i love this same age
this man has basically said if he lost
it all you'd be happy to be going
living in that box with him until he
said until he died
that's what he said until he died
that's the energy you're getting because
you're a guy that said you don't think
you should have to approach women they
should give you choosing signals
where would you rank yourself on a scale
from one to ten how tall are you
five ten five ten how much do you weigh
oh i worry about too what depending on
the
day between 280 285 so you're a fat
[ __ ]
yeah you think a 5 foot 10 almost 300
pound dude how much money you make
like 482 weeks four so you make 400
every two weeks so you make 800 a month
you make less than ten thousand dollars
how many twenty year old was hello oh no
dude i was a 20 year old and i was
making far more money than that in the
80s or minimum wage was 335 an hour so i
need to hear it
how long you got a big dick
i mean it's above average i ain't no run
jeremy no no no no no i actually if you
had a big dick i just said it wasn't
above average
i don't know what that is really you
know if you got a big dick or not stop
the [ __ ] every dude knows now he got
a big dick i know i got a big dick you
don't know
i mean you don't have a big dick that's
the point you don't have a big dick
you don't have a big wallet you're a bit
you're a fat dude
and you've got a lot of nerve thinking
you should get choosing signals at five
foot ten
and three hundred pounds making less
than a thousand dollars a month at 20
years old and women should approach you
what they get they don't even get a big
dick
so that was kevin samuels what did you
think
did you think what he said was true or
false i don't know
i feel like in some parts he could have
just been body shaming people
what's body shaming calling someone fat
is fat an insult it can be
interesting depending on the context you
use it on
do you think that if you're overweight
you have less options of people to date
no i mean apparently you do
but yeah i wouldn't care well yeah
that's
i think most girls don't care but more
guys care
i mean if someone's appearance shouldn't
alter
like anything you think of them so so if
a guy was shorter than you by a lot
would you care
would you data if he was rude to me then
i would make fun of him because it's
funny
but if he was nice to me i wouldn't care
so you did a guy shorter than you
i wouldn't care really my problem said
really most girls wouldn't date guys
shorter than them that's just because i
don't care
what you don't care about how tall he is
no these caribbean's like nice
yeah no okay
but
okay what do you care about so is that
it you just gotta be nice
yeah what about like hard working
i mean you could be like you can't be
like me lazy
okay do you have any other requirements
not really okay guys well
i guess anyone that's nice someday will
be her husband
nothing nothing else all right um okay
guys don't forget to subscribe to the
channel um bring that notification about
stop remember she's been like moving my
stuff this entire video
um bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos i will talk to you guys
next time subscribe to stop it